il mio motto di vita
e i problemi sono fatti per essere
risolti ebbe nella mia vita mi sono
scelto un problema bello grosso da
risolvere cioè quello della fame nel
mondo
ambizioso forse da pazzo come qualcuno
ha detto precedentemente
eppure però ho scelto di farne la mia
professione quando mi iscrissi al corso
di laurea in tecnologie alimentari ero
poco più che un adolescente non sapevo
minimamente di cosa si occupasse questa
figura professionale
poi pian piano andando avanti negli
studi ho capito che il tecnologo
alimentare veniva formato per tutelare
il consumatore
da un lato e dall'altro lato per
promuovere il profitto sostanzialmente
nel frattempo poi mi sono iscritto come
volontario in croce rossa
ho iniziato la mia esperienza di
volontariato ed è qui che il sogno ha
preso forma un sogno che prendeva in
considerazione le tecnologie alimentari
in chiave più umanitaria in chiave etica
perché quindi non declinare in chiave
umanitaria
la mia professione la mia futura
professione perché attraverso l'attivita
che poi sarei andato a fare in futuro
non aiutare le persone che stanno peggio
che addirittura non riescono a mangiare
dovete sapere che nel mondo esiste una
problematica gravissima che è quella
della fame che coinvolge 900 milioni di
persone
stiamo parlando quasi di un miliardo di
persone di questo miliardo di persone
sei milioni e mezzo di bambini al di
sotto dei 5 anni muore ogni anno
per cui molto spesso noi sentiamo
parlare la comunità scientifica
internazionale di soluzioni da poter
applicare per risolvere questo problema
sentiamo parlare di insetti sentiamo
parlare di microalghe sentiamo parlare
di una riduzione dell'allevamento
sentiamo parlare di ogm di incremento di
tutte quelle pratiche colturali atte a
migliorare le condizioni di salute delle
persone
abbiamo questa problematica dei sei
milioni e mezzo di bambini abbiamo le
possibili risoluzioni ma sono
risoluzioni a lungo termine sono
risoluzioni che richiedono molto tempo
per poter essere applicate eppure se ci
pensate 16 mila bambini muoiono ogni
giorno al di sotto di 5 anni per cui è
una problematica che deve essere
necessariamente approcciata non solo nel
lungo periodo ma anche nel breve periodo
è una problematica che richiede una
grande attenzione da parte della
comunità scientifica internazionale
negli ultimi dieci anni in effetti sono
stati sviluppati degli alimenti che si
chiamano terapeutici al rapido utilizzo
perché contengono poca acqua al loro
interno
e perché non necessitano di essere cotti
per cui possono essere consumati
direttamente da questi bambini allora si
potrebbe pensare ai vabbè abbiamo
risolto il problema in realtà il
problema c'è ancora perché se è vero che
questi alimenti hanno degli ottimi
risultati dal punto di vista del
recupero delle funzionalità di questi
bambini
dall'altro lato presentano delle
criticità come per esempio la presenza
del latte scremato in polvere al loro
interno che li rende difficilmente
riproducibili in loco dove serve
direttamente nei villaggi e quindi
questi alimenti non vengono
tendenzialmente prodotti anche se
teoricamente sarebbe possibile
direttamente in sul posto ma vengono
prodotti in occidente e poi esportati
dove serve in particolare in africa
il sud est asiatico e poi distribuiti
dalle organizzazioni governative e non
governative
qual è il problema in questo caso molto
spesso le crisi alimentari sono cicliche
si ripetono ciclicamente nei paesi in
via di sviluppo
perché basta una pioggia che non va
basta un periodo in cui non si
verificano precipitazioni nel tempo che
i raccolti falliscono e quindi tutto il
sistema di quello di quella regione va
in tilt e quindi quelle popolazioni non
riescono più ad approvvigionarsi dal
punto di vista alimentare e quindi le
organizzazioni governative le
organizzazioni non governative si devono
organizzare affinché possano fare fronte
al problema ma mentre si organizzano
l'orologio va avanti e quindi le vittime
aumentano a questo punto si inserisce il
mio sogno il mio sogno è quello di
produrre un alimento terapeutico al
rapido utilizzo con quelle
caratteristiche di cui vi ho parlato
prima
ma che sia capace di essere prodotto
direttamente in loco
questo alimento è fatto con ingredienti
che sono facilmente reperibili nei paesi
in via di sviluppo in particolare è
formato da soia sorgo e spirulina maxima
per quanto riguarda la soglia e sorgo 1
un legume l'altro un cereale e servono
per raggiungere un quantitativo di
proteine adeguato perché in quei paesi
non si muore tanto per mancanza di
energia ma si muove ma si muore e
piuttosto per mancanza di proteine e in
secondo luogo la spina maxima viene
raccolta poi successivamente essiccata
ed ha la potenzialità
incredibile
di essere un contenitore diciamo così di
sali minerali e vitamine formidabile
nella fotografia che vedete alle mie
spalle dotate una coltura di spina
maxima che una microalga un'alga
microscopica che quindi va osservata
microscopio se la si vuole vedere bene
che poi successivamente viene essiccata
ok il prodotto lo abbiamo ottenuto
avete visto nelle fotografie lo abbiamo
a disposizione però manca l'ultimo step
l'ultimo step è quello di costruire
l'impianto tera l'impianto produttivo di
questo prodotto in uganda
io sono attualmente un dottorando di
ricerca in scienze agrarie
agroalimentari e al dipartimento di
agraria della federico ii
però non abbiamo le disponibilità
economiche per costruire questi impianti
in uganda per cui volendo rimandare al
kit gradient non mi sono arreso e ho
fondato insieme ad amici colleghi
un'associazione attraverso la quale
abbiamo iniziato a raccogliere fondi
siamo andati avanti dopo un anno di
lavoro siamo arrivati a buon punto e
siamo sicuri che alla fine ci riusciremo
a costruire questo impianto che
riusciremo a realizzare questo sogno che
poi non è il sogno soltanto mio a mio
avviso ma è il sogno di 16.000 bambini
al giorno e poi un'ultima cosa con cui
vorrei concludere e restituire anzi dare
alle tecnologie alimentari
la dignità dal punto di vista etico
della sostenibilità e morale che merita
al cospetto della scienza grazie
[Applauso]